Trump says okay I don't want to I don't
want to debate the problem for him is
his base wants him to
they're all saying is he going to go
into the debate and I say I don't know
if you're leading by 50 and 60 and 70
points do you do that or not I don't
know should I okay you ready Paul we
take a free poll
should I do the debate
well maybe we'll do something else you
know see some people say yes but they
hate to say it because it doesn't make
sense to do it if you're leading by so
much but they like it for entertainment
value because they're selfish
they're selfish okay so he he misjudged
that one he usually has his finger on
the pulse of the crowd really well that
one he misjudged but it does expose a
real weakness in the campaign right now
which is everybody knows that Trump
doesn't really stand to gain very much
from debating and everyone wants him to
debate including his most fervent
supporters